good morning believe nation in today's
episode of believe life we're going to
be talking about the why and the how of
meditation my concentration is better
than my memory is better I'm more
comfortable in my seat which i think is
life call meditation has been a great
help to me in so many ways it basically
is the core of my existence you know
that that freedom that you get from
meditation is the kind of consciousness
you want to operate from I want to be
awake during the day and I don't want
the noise you separate me from whatever
greatness is is in here you know I want
to be able to operate from that space
let me awake while you work you know and
you want to have your head on straight
and meditation is the basis from which
you can really attract things but also
when you awake something's there you
just go get it you have noise in your
head you can't go get it so you want to
be awake you want me to get what you
imagine imagine is good for you you
imagine something and you calmly go out
and get it you know and a meditation
gives you that you know it's almost like
magic you know when you are awake things
become easier what from a practical
standpoint you know you just want to be
awake you know and you want to be able
to operate from it that's the awakened
state and meditation gives you that over
the last 50 years many studies have been
done that show the benefits of
meditations psychological and
physiological so you feel less
threatened you're less reactive you're
more rested you sleep better your blood
pressure gets lower your immune function
function gets a boost in general your
health improves not withstanding there
are thousands of studies on the health
benefits of
but because meditation takes you to a
core conscience to your core
consciousness it also awakens dormant
potentials in you so you're more open to
possibility you're less a bundle of
conditioned reflexes and nerves that's
triggered by people and circumstance
into very predictable outcomes of
behavior and reactivity you are more
creative because you're more
unpredictable and you recognize the
power of conscious choice making in the
power of intention I meditate every day
and it normally takes I do it in the
mornings and I'll do it for about 10 to
15 minutes and I think it's important
because it just it it sets me up for the
rest of the day you know it helps me
it's like this like it's like having an
anchor you know it's if I don't do it I
feel like I'm constantly chasing the day
as opposed to being able to be
controlled and dictate the day not that
you're you know calling the shots on
what comes forward but the fact that I
am set and ready for whatever may come
my way you know I have a calmness about
whatever comes my way and a poise and
that comes from starting the morning off
with meditation I'm a great supporter of
Transcendental Meditation I've been
using it for almost 40 years now and I
think it has is a great tool for anyone
to have and to be able to utilize as a
tool for for stress and stress of course
as it comes with almost every business
but especially considering the stress
that our men and women of the Armed
Forces would go through the anxieties of
going either in or coming from combat
and stress syndromes of various types I
think it's a great tool I think there's
enough
studies out there that show that
Transcendental Meditation or TM as we
all call it is something that could
benefit everybody I ran into this guy
that I've run into many times in the
beach very very pleasant man who told me
that he is a teacher in Transcendental
Meditation and I said well it's
interesting you mention it is it because
I feel like I should do something
because I felt like you know I'm just
overly worried and anxieties and all
this stuff and I feel like certain
pressures that I've never felt before
and then he says oh says Arnold it's not
uncommon it's very common a lot of
people go through this this is why
people use meditation Transcendental
Meditation as one way of dealing with
the problem and he was very good in
selling it because he didn't say it's
the only answer
he just is one of many and he says why
don't you try it
he says I'm a teacher there I've been
Westwood I would not be able to teach
you since we have a friendly of we're
friends and I have many uses there will
be another teacher that it will give you
a mantra and Probab and teach you how to
do it and then I can help you after that
is because I will be teaching abuse so
why don't we come up on Thursday and I
will be there I would introduce you to
the folks up there they went up there
took a class and I went home after that
and then tried it I said mister I gotta
give it a shot and that did 20 minutes
in the morning 20 minutes at night and I
would say within 14 days three weeks I
got to the point where I really could
disconnect my mind and as they say to
find this few seconds of this connection
and rejuvenate the mind and and also
learn how to focus more and to calm down
and I did that for it and that's all
they effect right away that I was much
more calm about all of the challenges
that we're facing me
okay so you sit quietly if you are
sitting on the floor sit you know with
either your legs crossed but be
comfortable if you're sitting in the
chair like I'm sitting then sit with
your feet grounded and your lap should
be your hand should be in your lap okay
back relatively erect don't slouch
you're gonna sleep otherwise which you
might be needing any way but in if
proper meditation don't slouch sits with
back relatively erect be comfortable be
relaxed close your eyes and for a minute
or so don't do anything you'll see
thoughts will start to come by
themselves
now as easily as those thoughts come
just think of the mantra don't force it
miss there so there will be thoughts and
there will be mantra at the same time
and as you start to think the mantra
even you can have the attitude that
you're not reciting the mantra you're
remembering the mantra or you're
listening to the mantra just an inner
attitude so you're not too focused on it
because if you're too focused on
anything is surface it's mental so now
what happens thoughts are coming mantras
covering thoughts are coming monsters
coming everything starts to get a little
uncertain you're getting there just by
the fact that things are getting
uncertain thoughts are random mantras I
know there's a proliferation of
uncertainty thoughts become vague but
also mantra becomes vague and if we do
it long enough 20-30 minutes then there
are periods where mantra and thought
cancel themselves each out okay which
means there is no mantra and there is no
thought and when there is no mantra and
there is no thought that's called pure
consciousness
that's the field of infinite
possibilities that's the field of pure
potentiality that's the field of
intention orchestrating its own
fulfillment that's the feel of pure
creativity that's the field observer
effect everything that we discussed that
morning that's right in that gap okay
but you cannot get into the gap by
wanting to get into the gap or thinking
I must get into the gap because wanting
to get into the gap is also a thought
also you cannot get rid of your thoughts
by saying I have to get rid of my
thoughts because that's a thought it's a
very simple mechanical understanding
that you don't force anything
thoughts mantra thoughts mantra there
you go
okay there'll be little dips and how
will you know there are little dips you
won't know where you are okay you will
have no sensation you will experience no
sound and you will have no thought
because sensation sound all this is
thought yeah everything is thought so
when you have you experience nothing
your non-local you have you don't know
where you are you don't have no location
but as you start to experience this and
we're gonna go a little deeper in this
it will not be a nothingness it will be
a wakefulness and you know we'll talk
about high states of consciousness
it'll be so wakeful that you will
experience it in waking and dreaming and
sleeping it will never leave you
here it is in summary sit comfortably
have an attitude of surrender observe
your breath in flows I Outlawz am when
sounds sensations thoughts or emotions
come to your awareness shift your
attention back to the I am and then let
God take over let the universe take over
and whatever happens is what was
supposed to happen if you fall asleep
that was supposed to happen if you have
too many thoughts that's great you were
releasing stress if you have lots of
emotional emotions coming up again you
release stress if you have sensations in
your body you feel Restless great you've
got an opportunity to release it and you
have had the benefits of meditation and
if you once in a while go beyond all of
that you go beyond the sounds the
sensations the thoughts the emotions the
I am the breath and enter the domain of
pure spirit then you were everywhere you
started from
if you want to learn more about
meditation
here are five valuable videos that will
help you take action
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Jose Cruz asked
me to so if there's a topic you want me
to cover in the next episode of believe
life leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of the
points that we discussed meant the most
to you is has the most mean and most
impact to you leave it in the comments
and I will join in the discussion thank
you guys so much for watching have an
amazing day
if you need to believe and I'll see you
soon